[Music]
rekka drop two trailers gave us an
insight that some Disney Princesses
might have a stronger bond than we
thought stay tuned to find out which
Disney Princesses seemed to be more than
just BFFs don't forget to hit that
notification valve to never miss another
video and be sure to check out our
community section for even more fun
do you love music check out our friends
over at the trendy for trending music
news now let's check out which Disney
princess would become BFFs Tiana and
Aurora let's start with the two that are
total opposites of one another it's hard
to believe these two would become a
perfect pair but the record Ralph -
trailer proved us wrong
this highly unlikely pair was seen
together asking vanellope what makes her
princess they both asked if she was
cursed but look at the way Tiana's
hugging Aurora's arm she looks terrified
at the teeny-tiny princess in front of
her how adorable is that these two must
have really created a special bond
if Tiana thinks Aurora's the one that
can protect her from tiny strangers
Moana Elsa and Anna let's go back to the
early part of the first trailer where we
see vanilla pee into the Disney princess
room we're still not sure what happened
and how she got there to begin with but
one thing we notice is that Moana Elsa
and Anna are all casually chatting in
the background Milan is leaning on her
boat paddle and talking to Elsa while
Anna appears to be listening they all
come from modern-day movies so there's
definitely something they could have in
common we're not even sure Moana ever
experienced what snow and ice look like
before so this must be all very
fascinating for her Cinderella and
Pocahontas Twitter was absolutely in
love with the unexpected interaction
between the two completely different
Disney Princesses it's not just Aurora
and tiana it's also Cinderella and
Pocahontas not only is it weird to see
them in a 3d animation it's weird to see
Cinderella casually brushing Pocahontas
hair as if she's known her for years we
also love how she actually discovered a
randomly thin Pocahontas hair the two
really look like they've been BFFs for
life
even those tuner Ella the movie came out
way before Pocahontas did out of all
interactions this one is definitely the
cutest and we hope we get to see more of
in the movie Merida and Moana this
interaction was only briefly shown in
the first trailer after the Disney
Princesses finally discovered Penelope
is in fact a real princess we see Merida
and Moana give each other a look of
agreement but people on Twitter pointed
out that these two could definitely be
BFFs they're both strong independent and
come with unique storylines that don't
require a love interest some people are
even pushing it as far as saying that
these two could totally end up being a
couple as well just look at the way
Moana looks if Merida
when she goes on her rants in the
Scottish accents that's hard to
understand for most princesses there she
turned on topic B no Jin tried to didn't
friends or lovers were totally here for
either Moana and Rapunzel Moana and
Rapunzel can be seen chillin together
during the Disney sleepover still photo
it almost looks like Rapunzel has her
legs on Moana which means that the two
must be super casual with each other
right the two movies were both modern
and unique in their own ways so we can
totally see how these two can become
BFFs their sense of humor is definitely
similar and Rapunzel could teach me
wanna have a fight with a frying pan and
Moana could definitely teach Rapunzel
how to sail and find her true calling
these two are perfect for each other
Rapunzel and Belle alright now these two
have definitely a lot to talk about we
can see both together when they asked
vanellope what makes her a princess they
both say if vanellope was kidnapped or
enslaved and they say it a bit too
enthusiastically don't they kidnap
turned slave no how could anyone be
happy about that
since Rapunzel read the same books over
and over again at the tower we have a
feeling she most likely read a few
things Belle enjoyed reading too they
both have similar personalities and they
were definitely meant to be each other's
BFF Elsa and Cinderella we're going back
to the sleepover picture and while
everyone was talking about the adorable
casual clothing we'd never seen Disney
Princesses wear before some people were
way to focus on Elsa and Cinderella it
looks as if the majority of Disney
Princesses were paying attention to the
adorable vanellope but something was
definitely up with these two twitter
found this photo and immediately pointed
out that the eye stare
game is strong with Elsa and Cinderella
and there's no way these two are just
BFFs unless those F's stand for
something else what do you think could
something be going on between those two
anna and tiana all right there's another
pair that caught our eye during the
sleepover Tiana and Anna are casually
sitting together not only is that
adorable considering they both have
totally different personalities and
would probably never begin the same
storyline Anna is also totally eyeing
that Starbucks cup these two could
definitely be besties
despite their slight difference in age
we see Tiana and Anna again in another
trailer where all princesses are taking
a selfie can you see where they are Anna
is in the far left and Tiana is right in
the middle did you catch them looking at
each other
they're totally adorable Penelope and
almost everyone let's be honest everyone
is best friends with vanellope at this
point it didn't start off well but it
definitely looks like it will end on a
perfect note it looks like some Disney
Princesses still have second thoughts
about Penelope even after she was
officially declared a princess can you
spot Pocahontas giving her as the
side-eye she's definitely not happy but
it looks like the rest of the princesses
are clearly BFFs with each other as well
as Penelope seriously there's nothing
we'd like more than taking a selfie with
all Disney Princesses in the same room
Penelope is so lucky all of them but
other than that it's pretty much seems
that all Disney Princesses get along
even Merida despite the fact we clearly
see others confused with her accent
she's still chillin with a lot of
princesses during the takes we've seen
so far it's absolutely adorable to
finally see them all together seriously
our minds are totally blown and we can
only hope that wreck-it Ralph too will
have several other Disney Princess
scenes as a matter of fact we wouldn't
mind if they make a third movie and just
totally focus on this new Disney World
everyone wanted to have what do you
think which Disney Princesses are each
other's BFF come let us know in the
comments and that's it for our video
before you leave make sure you check out
our friends at the trendy they'll keep
you updated on the latest news from some
of our favorite artists if you love
Ariana Grande Camila Cabello Nicki Minaj
and other chart-topping artists be sure
to give them a big thumbs up thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]